[Musica]
il cervello è senza dubbio una delle
strutture più complesse che siano
presenti nell'universo
consente di ragionare di pensare di
provare sensazioni di agire e quello che
si sta cercando di capire in che modo
consente di svolgere tutte queste
operazioni la complessità del cervello
dipende non solamente dall'enorme
quantità di elementi che lo
costituiscono
ma dalla grande quantità di interazioni
che questi elementi hanno tra di loro
per dare un'idea il cervello contiene
dell'uomo contiene circa 10 alla
dodicesima cioè
mille miliardi di neuroni e 10 alla
quindicesima cioè un milione di miliardi
di sinapsi e le sinapsi sono i punti di
contatto tra i neuroni
questo solamente per dare un'idea della
dimensione e della complessità di questo
sistema
dal punto di vista biologico
le domande fondamentali che ci si può
porre alle quali si può tentare di
rispondere mediante misurazioni
sperimentali o di osservazioni sono
quelle che vedete nella figura
sostanzialmente quando si attivano certe
aree cerebrali
voi sapete che il cervello a
un'organizzazione
architettonica molto particolare e
diverse aree sono deputate a diverse
funzioni o forse per dirla meglio
diverse aree sono coinvolte in diverse
funzioni
questo era un qualche cosa al quale si
può cercare di rispondere un altro
quesito molto importante e what cioè
cosa fanno dal punto di vista
computazionale di calcolo queste
strutture cerebrali perché
effettivamente il cervello è un sistema
di calcolo è costituito da neuroni che
formano reti e circuiti che calcolano
la domanda ancora più profonda e come
questi circuiti questi neuroni
sviluppano le loro operazioni
senza comprendere questa terra che noi
chiamiamo il one water and how della
funzione cerebrale senza comprendere
questa terra ma noi difficilmente
riusciremo a capire come funziona il
cervello e a valle di questo
noi dobbiamo anche porsi il quesito di
come queste conoscenze possono essere
applicate quindi possono essere
utilizzati in medicina in neurologia in
psichiatria in psicologia e possono
essere utilizzate nelle nuove tecnologie
quello che vedete è uno dei punti in
questa figura è uno dei punti
sostanziali uno dei punti chiave del
problema cioè la organizzazione
multiscala
il cervello è caratterizzato da una
strutturazione simile a quella degli
altri tessuti nel senso che parte da
un'organizzazione molecolare di base che
si ristruttura all'interno di cellule le
cellule si collegano tra di loro
formando quelli che chiamiamo i micro
circuiti questi micro circuiti sono uno
dei punti nevralgici dell'elaborazione
dell'informazione del cervello ce ne
sono tantissimi
si collegano tra di loro formando
strutture di mesoscala e di macroscala
la complessità
della struttura di macroscala
porta all'assemblaggio di quello che noi
chiamiamo il cervello quindi il cervello
è un insieme di strutture di macroscala
che contengono strutture più piccole di
mesoscala ancora più piccole di
microscala che sono costituite da
neuroni che sono costituiti da strutture
molecolari quindi questo problema di
multi sky o multiscala e il problema che
domina la complessità del sistema
nervoso
per capire in che modo il sistema
nervoso funziona dobbiamo affrontare il
problema multiscala
qui vedete alcuni esempi tratti da
misure di laboratorio nei quali vengono
mostrati
delle registrazioni e delle immagini dei
neuroni e della loro funzione nella
figura di sinistra vedete un neurone che
stato iniettato con un colorante
fluorescente e che è stato registrato
con tecniche di elettrofisiologia
cellulare vedete i potenziali d'azione
che sono questi picchi che rappresentano
la il segnale generato dai neuroni
nella figura di destra vedete invece
dell'immagine ottenute con un
microscopio confocale a due fotoni che
consente in una configurazione
particolare di registrare
simultaneamente l'attività di molti
neuroni quindi anziché di uno di molti
ci sono dei compromessi non vediamo beni
molti come vediamo l'uno però ne vediamo
tanti e in questo modo riusciamo ad
avvicinarci ad un monitoraggio ad
un'esplorazione delle funzioni del
microcircuito
quello che vedete qui è una
ricostruzione del cervello del topo
che è stata ottenuta da una serie di
esperimenti di iniezioni di traccianti
fluorescenti che sono stati trasportati
da gli assoni fino a nei loro punti di
destinazione in questo modo è possibile
ricostruire utilizzarli iniezioni in
tanti punti diversi del cervello
l'intero connetto ma
questi esperimenti sono stati raccolti
ed inseriti in quelli che noi chiamiamo
a plus o atlanti esistono tre anti molto
precisi del cervello del topo e si
stanno costruendo anche per il cervello
dell'uomo
dal punto di vista funzionale quando noi
andiamo sulla dimensione dell'intero
cervello dobbiamo pensare di registrare
segnali che tipicamente non sono più di
singolo neurone ma sono tenuti da molti
neuroni
simultaneamente sono chiamati segnali di
insieme
quello che vedete qui è una
ricostruzione ottenuta con tecniche di
risonanza magnetica nucleare funzionale
per immagini o m rai
della connettività cerebrale per tratti
trattografia quella che vedete qui
invece la controparte funzionale sempre
della m rai in questo caso si osservano
delle aree che qui vedete colorati in
rosso in giallo delle aree che si
attivano mentre il soggetto compie
determinati
tasca
queste
aree che si attivano rappresentano la
controparte anatomo funzionale della
funzionalità del cervello in quella
particolare operazione comportamentale
quindi noi riusciamo a vedere l'attività
cerebrale
a livello di singole cellule di molte
cellule di aree cerebrali che contengono
tantissime cellule in una di queste
macchie rosse sono contenuti milioni
milioni di neuroni quindi qui non
vediamo più i neuroni ma vediamo dove
questi neuroni si attivano
poi avete anche visto appunto che è
possibile generare il connetto ma
seguendo gli assoni dei neuroni oppure
ricostruendo i tratti con la risonanza
magnetica nucleare
bene questa è la base generale sulla
quale noi ci possiamo muovere per ho
detto tutto questo non abbiamo ancora
spiegato come questo insieme di
strutture di neuroni funziona
per poter capire in che modo il sistema
funziona abbiamo bisogno di modelli
cosa sono i modelli i modelli sono delle
rappresentazioni formali di
dati di regole che conosciamo dal punto
di vista empirico o che possono essere
trasmesse dalla teoria è che noi
riassemblano in una costruzione che
chiamiamo modello
normalmente noi continuiamo a costruire
modelli della realtà e le scienze
le scienze esatte la fisica la
matematica lavorano per modelli anche la
biologia può produrre modelli questi
modelli assomigliano molto i modelli che
si utilizzano in fisica questi modelli
consentono per la loro costruzione che
illustrerò a breve di collegare tra di
loro le diverse scale di complessità che
abbiamo menzionato quindi livello
molecolare con il
livello cellulare micro mesi e
macroscala
inoltre questi modelli consentono di
riempire i buchi nella nostra conoscenza
tramite delle regole costruttive
limitano e condizionano la ricerca dei
dettagli indirizzandoci su quelli che
sono più importanti per capire il
fenomeno che stiamo considerando e cosa
molto importante possano generare delle
nuove teorie delle nuove teorie sul
funzionamento del cervello che possono
essere poi validate oppure confutate
questo è il gioco della ricerca
scientifica di base
come vengono costruiti questi modelli
qui vedete un uno schema che sembra
complicato ma dividetelo in queste tre
aree gialla blu e rossa l'area gialla e
l'area della ricostruzione basata sui
principi della bio fisica delle cellule
conoscendo come sono organizzate le
molecole le cellule e i micro circuiti
possiamo ricostruirli tra poco vedremo
un esempio questa ricostruzione è
estremamente preciso dal punto di vista
del calcolo quindi dal punto di vista
informatico è anche decisamente pesante
arrivati verso la mese scade la
macroscala bisogna semplificare in
qualche modo di modelli viene indicato
nella figura per ottenere delle
rappresentazioni gestibili trattabili
dal punto di vista informatico e
concettuali
ok fin qui stiamo solo costruendo dal
basso verso l'alto questa strategia è
chiamata bottom up dal basso verso
l'alto può anche il reverse engineering
quindi ingegneria inversa
gli altri due e flussi nel disegno sono
quello blu e quello rosso in quello
rosso vedete una esemplificazione
della
strategia di modellismo che viene
utilizzata in ingegneria basata sulla
teoria di controllo l'attività di
controllo tende a generare delle
costruzioni teoriche e poi ad
implementarle per generare sistemi di
controllo
all'interno di questi sistemi di
controllo possiamo inserire i modelli
che abbiamo appena costruito quindi
finisce che riusciremo a trasportare la
biologia all'interno di questi
controller a circuito chiuso un qualcosa
del genere succede nel flusso blu un
altro tipo di flusso che proviene
dall'alto e va verso il basso quindi
definito topdown cosa succede partiamo
prendiamo le mosse per esempio dei
risultati di risonanza magnetica
nucleare e di utilizziamo per generare
dei cervelli artificiali questi cervelli
artificiali sono costituiti da sistemi
di calcolo che sono piuttosto
approssimativi al momento ma che possano
essere sostituiti successivamente con i
modelli
dettagliati che abbiamo generato dalla
biofisica delle cellule quindi in
entrambi i casi siamo in grado di
portare la biofisica delle cellule
ricostruita bottom up all'interno di
modelli che sono per loro natura top
down
in questo modo si stanno facendo
progressi nella comprensione delle
funzioni del cervello
dell'organizzazione multiscala del
cervello e si sta marciando verso
diversi tipi di applicazioni
ora procederò per esempi e più
velocemente qui vedete un esempio di
questa procedura in cui abbiamo la
ricostruzione di un neurone modellizzato
a sinistra che viene semplificato e il
pallino nero che viene poi inserito
all'interno di un circuito e il disegno
contanti pallini colorati e poi questo
microcircuito può essere inserito in un
cervello virtuale oppure in un
controllore robotico addirittura in un
robot vero
al di sotto vedete tutti i piani di
analisi sperimentale che ho mostrato
prima e che servono per costruire e
validare i modelli
tenete conto che modelli sono sempre
validati rispetto a dati sperimentali
in questo esempio vedete un'applicazione
sulla quale passerà velocemente
dell'utilizzo dei modelli a livello di
microscala quindi a livello neuronale in
questo esempio un modello di un neurone
del cervello viene costruito sulla base
di dati
ottenuti da esperimenti di
elettrofisiologia e farmacologia
questo modello consente di rappresentare
molte funzioni del neurone ma non tutte
ne manca certamente qualcuna perché il
modello non rappresenta tutti gli stati
funzionali quindi predice tre dice
quello che manca quello che manca viene
cercato e questo è il punto numero uno e
si introduce una nuova funzionalità
nella membrana del neurone che un nuovo
canale ionico il modello funziona bene
tuttavia non riesce a predire
esattamente alcune caratteristiche del
potenziale d'azione che avete visto
prima e per poterle predire è necessario
secondo modello
anche questo secondo modello funziona
bene però non sa ancora anticipare le
caratteristiche di trasmissione dei
segnali lungo gli assoni si fa un terzo
modello in tutti i casi questi modelli
sono supportati da misure sperimentali
piuttosto complesse che rivelano nuove
proprietà delle cellule quindi si
continua ad individuare nuove proprietà
cellulari basandosi sulle predizioni del
modello anche l'ultimo passaggio quello
che vedete nel pannello di destra e che
è avvenuto solamente l'anno scorso
rappresenta un'ulteriore evoluzione del
modello che ad un certo punto non riesce
a predire alcuni stati funzionari
mancanti vengono cercati nuovi canali
ionici si individuano si mettono nel
modello è il modello si mette funzionale
e rappresenta a questo punto tutto
quello che noi sappiamo della funzione
della cellula che è stata modellizzata
questo è un esempio che vi dimostra la
potenza di questo sistema è anche la
precisione che può raggiungere se viene
messo in parallelo con le misure
sperimentali
questo è un esempio di un ciclo del
tutto analogo a livello di micro
circuito in cui vedete il micro circuito
che viene modellizzato vengono fatte
delle predizioni sull'organizzazione
spaziale e temporale dei potenziali
d'azione nel circuito
queste vengono poi cercate a livello
sperimentale vengono trovate validando
il modello e quindi scoprendo di fatto
come circuito si comporta in questo
spazio multidimensionale multi
parametrico facendo alla fine delle
predizioni su come questo circuito
filtri ed elabora i segnali che riceve
quindi questo è quello che modelli
possono insegnarci sulla complessità del
nostro sistema
qui vedete un altro tipo di predizione
queste fatte rispetto a dati ottenuti in
vivo e quindi siamo saliti ancora di più
di scala non sono più dati ottenuti vite
nei laboratori e su tessuti sperimentali
ma in vivo
e qui vedete che il circuito viene
inserito in un controller robotico
questo controller robotico può
sviluppare diversi tipi di tusk e in
particolare è in grado di apprendere
dall interazione con l'ambiente
non vi sto a spiegare tutti i task ma di
fatto l'apprendimento nel circuito non è
dato da noi dobbiamo solamente le regole
perché il circuito apprenda
l'apprendimento è basato esclusivamente
sull'interazione della robot con
l'ambiente quello che succede che
vengono generati dai pattern e di
attività cellulare quelli che ci sono a
destra
basati sulla generazione di quelle che
chiamiamo plasticità sinaptica
anche questa è la studiamo in biologia
ma poi la inseriamo nei modelli il
modello con plasticità sinaptica in
grado di predire le funzioni cellulari
necessarie a generare un comportamento
questa volta
qui vedete l'inserimento del circuito in
un cervello virtuale e il circuito a
questo punto viene trascinato non da un
controller di un robot che la
costruzione che in un certo modo
imponiamo poi ma viene trascinato
dall'attività globale del resto del
cervello quindi la situazione è più
vicina alla fisiologia quello che vedete
che il sistema inizia a reagire alla
input che viene dell'arresto del
cervello generando dei pattern e di
attività che a questo punto sono in fase
di analisi ma promettono di svelare come
circuito funziona nel contesto in cui è
stato generato
questo è l'ultimo passaggio che vi
voglio mostrare è quello della
modellizzazione del cervello dell'uomo
ho già accennato a questa idea
vedete che dalle misure di risonanza
magnetica nucleare e mereilles si
ottengono delle ricostruzioni di
trattografia e di connetto mica che
vengono importate in quello che noi
chiamiamo lo spazio virtuale del
cervello che vedete a destra
le aree diventano nodi i tratti
diventano
sostanzialmente gli hedge come li
chiamiamo che collegano i nodi e si
ricostruisce la architettura del
cervello attenzione che questo può
venire fatto su un singolo soggetto non
abbiamo bisogno di ottenere dati medi si
fa su una singola persona
a questo punto all'interno dei nodi
vengono messe delle funzioni dinamiche
delle cosiddette funzioni neuro
dinamiche sono dei sistemi chiamati
massenet orali o
campi medi di attività neuronale che
generano attività elettrica questa
attività elettrica finisce per generare
quella mappa che vedete è che si chiama
mappa di connettività simulata
funzionale simulata
paragonandola con la mappa che si
ottiene della risonanza magnetica invece
di
funzionalità questa volta no simulata ma
sperimentale otteniamo la stima della
connettività dell'intero sistema nervoso
chiaramente questi risultati possono
venire utilizzati adesso in medicina e
in high city quindi nel sistema dello
sviluppo di nuove tecnologie
per poter gestire questa operazione
presso l'università di pavia stiamo
realizzando un hub che consentirà di
coordinare a livello europeo la
generazione dei modelli computazionali
del sistema nervoso e di gestire le
applicazioni in campo biomedico e in
campo tecnologico